This is FRESH AIR I'm Dave Davies filling in for Terry
Gross son of Saul the hunger Aryan film set in the Nazi
concentration camp Auschwitz Birkenau won the grand prize at the Cannes Film Festival.
It opens in New York and Los Angeles today. Terry interviewed the director and star
of the film. Earlier this year.
Let me say right at the start here. I usually try to avoid Holocaust
movies I've read books about the Holocaust I've seen feature films and
documentaries and at this point I don't want to go to a theater to watch
such unbearable suffering. Unless it adds to my understanding of the Holocaust or is
an exceptionally well made
film but I went to see the new film Son of Saul and it is an
exceptionally well made film and it left me with a better understanding of how Auschwitz
Birkenau operated as an extermination
factory and of the Jews who the Nazis forced to be the workers in that
factory Jews who were called Sonderkommando as their job was getting fellow
Jews into the gas
chamber the corpses into the ovens and then disposing of the ashes. I have
two guests to talk about making the
film gazer Roehrig stars as Saul a slender Garion
Jew who is a Sonderkommando in
Auschwitz Roehrig was born in one thousand nine hundred seven grew up in Budapest
and has lived in New York for the past fifteen years he had a few small acting roles years
ago but he's mostly a poet and fiction writer and is a graduate of the Jewish
Theological Seminary in New
York. Laszlo Nema she directed and co-wrote son of Saul he was born
in Budapest Hungary in one thousand nine hundred seven moved to France as a child and has
returned to Hungary son of Solace his first feature film.
That's on Amish gazer Arik welcome to FRESH AIR. The opening
scene of son of Saul is very chaotic and we don't really know
what's happening at first but we soon. Find out what's happening is
that the whole transport of Jews has just arrived at Auschwitz.
They've been taken off. I guess it's a train and
they're there in the camp and there's just chaos you hear like screaming and crying
and German commands and they're basically being told to go into this room take off their
clothes hang up their clothes on the hooks and go into this
large group shower so that they can get clean because there's hot soup waiting
for them in the soup is going to get cold unless they hurry
up and also that they're going to have good work to do because like the Germans need good
workers and there's interesting jobs to like hurry up and get your shower so we
can get moving and of course the showers the gas chamber and it's
a really chaotic and also horrifying scene and you see how they really don't
know or they don't know for sure what they're in store for and we
also see the zonder commandos including you know the
main character Saul who gave the plays you know kind
of hurting them in and getting their clothes hung up and everything.
Can you talk a little bit. Laszlo about starting the film with that and the kind. The sense of kind
of chaos that you wanted to create and the lack of understanding the lack
of total comprehension and in the Jews who have just been taken to Auschwitz.
I
wanted to convey something of the fact that the camp was a mixture of
chaos an organization something that you could really see in movies
because movies. Usually they talk about how well organized
the camps were but actually the camps were
chaotic where makes YOUR of languages
and noise and and diff and death would
be around about you as a prisoner you wouldn't know when you
would be
dead or when you would be alive.
Yeah and this is something. The lack of predictability. That's in
the in the experience of the prisoner just something that has never
been you know communicated.
So we want to do to merge the viewer a new experience of the of the
main character.
The film was shown through the eyes of a Sonderkommando would you describe who
the Sonderkommando is
were and the work that they were forced to do.
So there's on their. COME ON THOSE were a group of prisoners who were
actually separated from the rest of the other
prisoners male prisoners who were forced to assist the Nazis in
the extermination process. These were the prisoners who had to company
the deported people to the gas chamber and then take out
their corpses and and burn the corpses in the audience of the crematorium.
And then scattered ashes.
So these were the people who were the heart of the extermination machine.
They
were in exchange better fed and better clothes
but they knew that they would be liquidated in a few
months and they actually made notes of
secretly of their everyday lives and. In their experience
and and their rebellion also the dipper trying to plan and carry
out this act this rebellion actually took place
in October ninth and forty four which is the only armed rebellion the history
of of
Auschwitz and your film is in part about that
rebellion that the film has
in its core also a rebellion that that is being carried out. Whereas.
The main character is trying
to bury his this boy who who he thinks is
his is his.
So much of the. It was about the industry of death the work of getting the people into the ovens shoveling
out their ashes dumping the ashes in the
river and I know some of the source material comes from journals that
the zonder commandos kept and buried in the hopes that someone in the future
would find them and some of these journals were found years later.
I'd like you to each talk about the experience of reading
those and to describe a passage or two that stands out in your mind that helped inform.
Lazlo the writing and directing of the movie or gays to your performance in the
film. I came upon these right things in France
and then years ago it was an incredible experience
reading those manuscripts this so-called scrolls of
Auschwitz. I was transported in to develop present of
these men who witnessed the extermination
firsthand these tanks were put into
the ground before the rebellion of the zone the commandos
for example they
on the revenue called Judge Diane
who was a member of theirs and their commando his name was labor long force who
was opposed to a member of his and their commando
he had a very factual description of their everyday
lives and and. And day by day all the
new transports that would
come one day. A group of three hundred
Jack young boys arrived to the crematorium. And
they're still full of life and full of some kind of
hope and but they had the same time and they they feel
that this is the end and he just he just describes
how you know every step of how they had to dress and go to the gas
chamber and his owner kimonos going to talk to them. Because it's
absolutely forbidden to talk to the to the New Year transports so
it's the stakes are really at the heart of the extermination machine
and for that reason helps me.
In fact finding ways to tell the story from
within the camp and not some kind of story that that belongs to the
post-war period of the retrospective
story. And gave the how did Reid reading these
testimonies affect your performance these are like first person
testimony right well there was about the
hundred was all that on the members who were actually survived the
Holocaust who were liberated and I think it's important to point out
that this one they're going to members in that terrible rap.
Differed despised by the other
prisoners and not only by the other prisoners were so much so they had a terrible
rabbit when the Soviets came to Auschwitz they were asking
around you know the Jews who was on their commando member and they shot
the person right there.
And the Soviets argued that your version than the Nazis because you're killing your own.
Brothers and Sisters. So the reason why
there are so few accounts from actual
Sonex surviving zone they're going to members is
because they've are very hesitant to even to their own
family families you know in what capacity. Were they the
camps so I relied on the have heavily on
these scrolls of Auschwitz and also a book and four hundred pages
book called That would be wept of the doubt two years which is a
for their own good I was at the audition the story in from the
zero and he in the course of like twelve two years.
Conducted this. Painstakingly detailed into it he was he was on there comando
members eight of them there's about twenty alive now. About
the you know their daily routine these twelve hour shifts the night.
What were you doing exactly one of them I think feeling.
Miller check. Do you mean accuracy survive five lucubrations.
He says that there was this consensual rule among
them that even though they were
schlepping their bodies on the floor when it came to a child
they carried the child to the ovens in their laps. So
that was speaking to me as a father
for you mention how hated the zonder commandos were and
how this Soviets would even execute them and I found out
who had been a sounder commando because they had collaborated with the Nazis and as you put
it helped kill their own.
How did you both deal with the moral question that you're making a film about
these people who are forced to participate in the extermination of
their own people.
Now if they didn't do it they would be killed but you could you could argue better to be
killed than to kill your soul. While killing others
like that so you know I'd love to hear what you
both the process you've gone through of thinking that through.
I in full agreement with dreamily. I think that the most
the
monic crime of the Nazis was exactly
that forcing informing compiling
these special squads on the disk. You know threat of
death to assist in the killing process and
by doing so they deprived even from
the solace of being
innocent. To make out of the
able
to shift the burden of guilt on to the victims
and so the seas I think that this is the most fun forgivable the same is
true by the V.A. one hundred the Nazis used then forced the
leaders of the Jewish consuls all over in Europe to provide them
lists the sort of things like
that is basically making. The Jews partners in
their crime. You know. Trading them
down to the rock bottom of their mortality and succeeding in that.
So I think we have to suspend judgment. I have up most of the
suspect for this on their commando members who did commit suicide
and that were not to be linked to you know participate you know
this but I would never be so
arrogant for women aren't armchair twenty
fifteen to label and blame
these on their condo my members who had families on the other
side of the wall in the camp and they did their best to survive.
When they did commit suicide those who did what did
they do the risk. They were sneaking into the gas
chambers and actually. One of them wrote that he
was order the. In the chamber. And there was a women
from his village and the minister on and him and pushed him out saying V have to die you
don't and you know this is this is just not right. Just
just bleed just just go on because you don't know what tomorrow
brings you have to bring the message to the future. That's
it that's the idea.
So the question is whether there's
hope that can still exist in the middle in the midst of outer.
Loss of humanity and and death.
Terry. Yes. You know I share your story real briefly that I think those more than anything
about being is on their commander member. Yes please. OK so I
do not know any of them in person but I do know one of their son.
So there is this man invest just
or David whose father was in Auschwitz but that all
he knew that his father was in Auschwitz his father did not like to talk about
it and he's laid these years about to pass and he
gave his wheel in an envelope to his son David
and after the funeral in the presence of the family's lawyer
they opened the envelope and they learned that
his Father's
Will is to be cremated
and not only that but he wants. He's ashes to be carried back to
Auschwitz and placed in the oven and that was a. Obviously
a shock they did not doubt that his father was on their Come on that number.
He mentioned that in the will that he had been an
omission having the will correct.
And so basically by asking.
David to carry his back to Auschwitz I think he would he
was making a couple of points One
is that this is the people to whom I belong to even more than to
my family. That's the community I belong to so
that what
I was eating came and that's what it must have been like to to to
be he's on there comando member and
for you know using and years out to do this task beach
by the way just to be a little bit more like factual and descriptive the way that happened is that there
was an initial selection who goes to the gas and who goes to the bottom. And there was
a
secondary selection when the Nazis came into the Barak and
they lined up the people making the males and the pig the one that the
strongest stocky and they did not tell them of course what's the nature of the job they just
said you're going to get good food you can have a different
life. You know join us and so in beat by they learn the in the
following days what was this all about this a complete shock. You
know so. So these people. I mean on the left the strongest of the strongest the Saints
or the you know was
but humanly speaking I don't think these people had really a choice to
make you know it was it was just they were thrown into the situation.
It was a life and death matter and they just wanted to make sure that they think the next breath not
from the
gas. One of the central perhaps the
central story line in a movie has to do with gays or the character that
you play the Sonderkommando that you play finding a boy who survived the
gas chamber who barely survived he's choking he can barely
breathe and your character would like to save him.
But what actually happens is I won't go into detail I'll save some of the stories
for people to find out for themselves in the movie but he dies pretty
quickly and so GAZEY your character wants to at least try to
save this boy's soul least that's how I interpret it and
so he wants to find a rabbi to say cause for this boy he doesn't want the boy in
the ovens he doesn't want the boy autopsied by you know the Nazi
doctors and then his mission becomes to find a
rabbi to get somebody to say the prayer for the dead cottage and to give this boy
a burial and he's doing it at the expense of doing some things
he's supposed to be doing to prepare for the
rebellion but he he feel. He can't say the living but perhaps he
can save the soul of this one dead boy
and I want to know what you were thinking as the person playing this
character when I
think you know I think he's that the happiest person in the movie. I
think that I'm talking about from that moment onwards when he you know sees and
meets the
boy I think that. Their
resistance is taking place on two different levels in the movie. One is and it's
obviously completely legitimate is
a political biological way of resisting and just to get the hell out
of here and that's fine and it's important. He
I think is resisting on the one lever higher than that and I think
that he's doing something for someone
else. You know they were it's he's not concerned with the
survival of his physicalities survival is his life he somehow
goes through an experience by seeing these boys each is obviously a mirror image actually assigned even though
it's historically the quarter they did
happen that people survived the gas chambers.
But but
still he took that as a sign and
brought him back to normalcy and there's a very few things that are for sure to have
a
life but I think every day to lead young earth with their glee. That you
know feeding the hungry or courting the poor birding that that is just. Just
the most human thing you can do and it's about excellence
human thing. I mean animals do not bury you know they leave their fellows
to
decompose the Dewberry and he just
by
ignoring the rules of the place an obviously
this is completely prohibit the through like slapping around dead bodies and bury
them there.
He does the see God's the seed creation the context and he does the right thing and
that gives same purpose.
I want to quote something that you said Laszlo about why a cascade in
the leading role. You said he's at once old and young handsome and
ugly ordinary and remarkable deep and impassive quick witted and slow.
Is that what was your reaction to that.
I agreed
half perfect.
This film was on your face the whole time. So last well why did you want to shoot it that way
so that we're almost
always seeing gazes face and sometimes the actions happening in back of him and sometimes it's
happening in front of him but we're almost always seeing
him. We wanted to do a portrait
of a man inside a concentration camp and not sure more and tell
more and describe the entire camp we wanted to really take
the measure of one man because seeing one person gives
the
measure of and of reference so that the viewer can
really feel not see but feel something of the enormity of
the horrors of the Concentration
Camp good so how did you prepare for having the camera on your face for so long I
mean actors tried not to telegraph emotions through using a lot of
facial expressions your character is trying to
keep his own soul alive by saving the soul of someone else
but he feels that they're all dead anyways that their death is just inevitable
and that they've already been killed in some ways even though they're still alive.
How do you get that to register on your face without
overly demonstrating what you're
feeling. I was of many to think a whole lot.
How on earth. Were these people are able to do this you
know just how what what's how deep you go
down to become like a zombie in the you have to really turn
off your humanity your empathy
and just have that
look pilot flame you know that's
pork because that's was exactly the intention.
I think that on the one hand the so-called dollar cost was a very
barbaric and yet it was very sophisticated if you think
about the psychologically especially the in order to destroy God's image and I say it's
not enough to transform man into the walking
corpse in order to the story God's image in us. You
have to do. He's humanity and humanity I think
is located in a lot of real good as a stable and that's exactly what they
targeted
install and once he became this
robotic monster who is just doesn't see what that front of him and he
doesn't hear what you know right around the surroundings he's just
going on a V. TES duty. How how do you
right through that state
of mind. I was thinking of that they're reading. Running. They're
reading eating during sleeping.
And I don't know there's no formula or something I can fix you know Sherry
and you like
how but one thing I can tell you is that I did
my best to stay in nineteen forty four I was not socializing
having coffees with people at
Drake's trying to really focus and I think if if it verdict.
It's really due to last will and the team. I mean the or working
on the same movie.
Laszlo you cast gays in the leading role and he had to be good
in this sort of. Film to work
and fortunately he's quite quite good but he doesn't have a lot
of acting experience. Why in the world would you cast
someone worked out for the best but why in the world would you cast somebody who didn't
have much
experience when so much in hands on their ability to be
able to hold the camera.
You know from the outside it seems a little reckless to you know for a first
project first film making a film on the
Holocaust having. You know an actor who is.
You know hasn't acted for years and you know being just
a first timer is you know supposed to so many so
many problems
and and and traps along the way especially with this kind
of risky strategy that we do we had to
portray the main
character. So I think there were a lot of things that were a little bit you
know crazy. I guess we were a little bit unconscious of the dangers but at the same time
we were very conscious of the you know the more reality that we
were you know dealing with and we try to
respect you know the subject and the
dead you know that we were talking about and also the
living and and
and and I think that I needed someone for disbarred
who was already so the main character
he I needed someone
who when the you know did edition start doesn't have to
perform and when just it should start doesn't have to you know you
know and to do something very
specific but actually has in himself already a lot of
things that the main character
has. Granted
this subject matter did not start with the movie.
I was forty six when I was playing this role and I felt even just by
a leading the script that felt like my whole
life to be honest. Was like just one big breath
Gratian for the
soul and what I mean by that is you know I
think I have some idea of what a father he's losing my own father at four and then I
went to war
so and learned Polish and leave the in Poland and when I
was there I was nineteen at the time saw the camp Auschwitz
near Cracow was still under the care of the
Soviets and I wended in that the Simberg day. And what it meant to
be just the one the news it ended up to be like a month and I
actually ran to the room. You know Shan shame which is the current name of I
should think
Polish and I went there every single day from the opening to the evening. I told
my first point in book. Single only about sheets.
And and so you know and then I got to be a father.
Thank God for four due to four
children and of course my grandfather who was liberated from
the press to get the SO I felt like a lot of aspects of my personal story came into
fruition in this
or less well how was your family affected by the
Holocaust. Well I think I don't have real family because
of the Holocaust. I have a very small
family and
actually there's a sort of shadow family. It's you know
stuck in nineteen forty four and the shadow family is haunting
us you know or accompanies us. I can feel the
presence of it all and I think I'm from a job. Rationed
that didn't have a do really direct
access to this period but at the same time things were stories were
transmitted and my mother had the time you know when I was
really little a Qur'an five or six. Told me about how
their grandparents were deported and killed. You know she adds and told me about
all the stories that she she has
heard sure. So actually I think nobody really spared
me in this process and I was I was very
aware of the destruction that we are carrying it on ourselves.
Especially in Jews from Eastern Europe really have this feeling. I think of
this destruction to still present Very much
so whether many Jews left in Hungary when you were growing up.
You know medically I mean this is the largest Jewish community on the map between the French and the Russian
I'm liking of our SO THE END UP THERE is about one hundred thousand Jews in
their video simulate the Phantom I just just like about the nomadic bliss.
So yes that's a logical mind.
You know the same thing I think it's a very low key presence. I think and also
because of of pressure from society to remain low key and
low profile.
How frightening was it to hear stories about extermination and the extermination of your
own family when you you will see when you were fine I mean so many
people adults don't want to expose their children to like a violent
movie but then other children girl up in actual violence and there's no protecting them.
Your parents shared with you the truth about the
violence that had preceded you and that had taken so many lives
including lives of your family.
Yeah I think it was very very frightening but at the same time
I preferred to you know. And then to be spared
and not protected because I think or
I wouldn't have been prepared for this
world with without
knowing because also this you know in this world is very much affected
by what happened during the Second World War in this world still not to
have has not come to terms and Europe has not come to terms and the Hungary isn't going to
do so I think it's.
It was a brain for process but at the same time this.
Well
I can say that that that made the region really attractive to me because
I just heat and heated all these and these sort of built out
Italian system and so what I was persecuted by the comedy it's that was just
very attractive to
me and later on of course I later
and sadly that large section of
the religious establishment daring to call me somebody informers and they call a call operate
to desist the and so it wasn't enough to be a police to be
like necessarily in the opposition of the as you
seem but I do remember that and. Kind of
by inclination I'm some of the pew least. And that's that's why this whole charge
of collaboration of what is on there call on the
limbers I found it in a very personal way because in high
school you know growing up you know one party system. You know you had
to make choices and every choice that you made in this regard had really
important
consequences in terms of being accepted and you know was it a part of disease so I
ended up being
Boland for universities because I was into the link to become a member of the
youth communist party which was basically practically obligates
Syrian me my whole haikus high school class one day joined
a party and ice. You know their
words. Yes I think it is the Verde.
Q.T.S. thorough enough events that the Jews basically ended up from want but
that Italian system Nazi Germany or the Nazis or playing Hungary
and basically were thrown into that the
other. And so for a while embracing Judaism and
racing religion was a way of defining define communism. But you know
all religions have their own no authority authority structure too. Did
you belt rebel against that structure the time.
That's why that's why I do then I don't think I was pretty close on the track to become a rabbi and that's why
I decided not to because I write oh yeah I felt that the individual
autonomy overrides any sort of group membership and
I feel that didn't feel like I I would
be able honestly to represent any sort of institution
I just I did that and that I couldn't.
So or movement.
Yeah yeah. So do you feel like you've left
the Holocaust Now do you feel like you can you
can. Stop obsessing about it now that the film is over
because it's a very
bleak place to to have lived for so long while you were making the
movie and I'm not trying to compare your suffering making the movie to people
who actually were in the camp suffered. You know I understand there's a difference but you
voluntarily immersed
yourself in this for a long time and now outside of doing interviews
about it you're on you're on the other end like you've come out of that tunnel so.
Are you feeling a sense of relief and with what's next for each of you.
Well
I thought why I'm making the film that I would understand more.
By the Holocaust slaves think I did maybe I listed more factually but I
didn't ever really
understood but it's still I think part of me and it's all almost
a jennet genetic thing you know you cannot get rid of your genes.
I guess disease are that it does. The Holocaust is now in our genes.
I
don't think I plan to leave that topic behind and it's not because
I'm upset is the No way like it would be
caught fairly like a political got for me that I know I'm for life
and and and and and but. But at
the same
time I mean you know one third of the jury was.
Purdy's murder and pretty soon after one of every three come bodie
and was murdered and then be that into dog food Rwanda and Isis and just look
around I again
this is this this this sad sad ass. It's
a pattern that is going on and I'm not what what I'm obsessed
vid is not the whole the
cost per se is is that the naked shameless cool
T. that again many faceted in nineteen forty four five
The is just feeling among us I then that's what bothers
me the most and the you know governments they call them these kind of actions but
so
what they still take place as the speak and so did it really
became part of the legacy of modernity and and
and the ever verdant the old told Terry that the you know
this kind of barbarism belongs to the past you know that the hordes of
Genghis Khan and all that
and and it it eclipsed by the rationality of the
Enlightenment and. And that's what I grew up made and
and once it kind of hits me in the face. I would
not let myself to pass and close the book on the
Holocaust because I
think it's rude to be scape is and I think I think to
keep my sense of reality really and
clear and in the valley that I just can't can't
overlook it.
I want to thank you both so much for talking with us and thank you for making this movie. Thank
you thanks for having
us gaze a reg stars in Son of salt. Laszlo
Nimish directed and co-wrote the film. It opens in New York in Los Angeles
today.